let's bring in canary ceo a company that
provides drilling and production
services to u.s oil companies and author
of switching gears the petroleum-powered
electric car
dan eberhard all right dan
how difficult is it for you guys to get
underneath the ground and get that oil
out you must jump through a ton of
hurdles
oh it's an awful lot of work an awful
lot of hard work really every day an
awful lot of paperwork
for the oil companies our customers to
be able to drill
they must throw up so many roadblocks
whether it's like a salamander
that's protected or you know you might
have to probably take someone out to
dinner at the department of interior
there must be so many goofy things you
guys must have to go through
yeah i know look it's it's pretty
difficult and you know there's
definitely been a switch from the trump
administration to the bide
administration i feel like they just
keep throwing wet blankets at us
uh and keep trying to you know put hold
the industry back and keep us from doing
what we do every day
do they ever call you guys on the phone
and say hey boys uh the price of gas is
what now over almost 450 do they say hey
maybe you could uh help us out have you
heard from them
no quite quite the opposite but i'll
tell you it really upsets me when they
talk about this price gouging the the
people that i know in the oil field
which supports about 11 million jobs in
the us they work hard every day we go
out there we get dirty we you know work
very very hard and these jobs are very
difficult and not that easy sometimes
and to just hear these people from the
shinsaki from the white house podium you
know go on and on about 9 000 leases
and not being drilled when she doesn't
know the difference between a lease and
a permit is just really frustrating i'd
like to invite her to watford city north
dakota or odessa texas come see what we
do every day come get some mud on your
boots and come come find out the real
difference in a lease and a permit and
what we're doing every day yeah that's a
bs talking point and everybody knows it
and it's a tough job it's a dirty job
and it's a dangerous job and she's
trying to make you guys out to be
war profiteers uh anything you want to
tell the president of the united states
look president biden you know we're
willing to do our part we can definitely
increase american production stop asking
opec for more oil stop asking venezuela
for more oil ask texas ask north dakota
ask oklahoma we can do it here with
american jobs but just get out of our
way let us have the pipelines to
transport the oil get the uh you know
permits through stop talking nonsense
about leases when you guys don't know
what you're talking about and and let us
do it just get out of our way we can do
it here and we can we can push the price
down and produce more oil right here in
america let's unleash america's energy
and let's do it right here right now
biden got out of the way on the border
seems like he should get out of the way
here in texas and north dakota thank you
so much for joining us we really
appreciate all the hard work you guys do